5G is a software-defined network.
It means that while it won't replace cables entirely,...
...it could replace the need for them...
...by largely operating on the cloud instead.
This means it will have a hundred times better capacity than 4G,...
...which will dramatically improve internet speeds.
For example, to download a two-hour film on 3G...
...would take about 26 hours.
On 4G, you'd be waiting six minutes,...
...and on 5G you'll be ready to watch your film...
...in just over three and a half seconds.
But it's not just internet capacity that will be upgraded.
Response times will also be much faster.
The 4G network responds to our commands in just under 50 milliseconds.
With 5G, it will take around one millisecond,...
...400 times faster than a blink of the eye.
Self-driving cars, for example, require a continuous stream of data.
The quicker that information is delivered to autonomous vehicles,...
...the better and safer they can run.
For many analysts, this is just one example...
...of how 5G could become the connective tissue for the internet of things,...
...an industry that's set to grow threefold by 2025,...
...linking and controlling not just robots, but also medical devices,...
...industrial equipment and agricultural machinery.